قضية الفلسطينية والهتاف بالحرية
لفلسطين. بينما خرجت مظاهرات
يعتذر. بعد الغواصات هي استراليا
تتخلى عن مروحيات فرنسية
وتستبدلها بامريكية. الحرب
الروسية الاوكرانية تكاد تخرج
اسرائيل. مؤكدا ان واشنطن لا
تزال الشريك الامني الاكبر
مناشدة اياه بالتدخل للافراج عن
اسراها المحتجزين لدى حركة حماس
اعطاء ترخيص لليميني المتطرف
راسمس بالودان من اجل حرق نسخة
تعود للواجهة. بعد انشغال العالم
بحرب اوكرانيا وتجاهل الجميع
بقطاع غزة منذ الفين واربعة عشر.
وذلك حسب وسائل اعلام اسرائيلية
ازمة عالمية. الشرطة البريطانية
تغرم رئيس الوزراء ريشيسوناك
للرياض بحسب بلومبرج لتستنجد تل
ابيب بابا الفاتيكان فرانسيس
الجماعات الاجرامية بحسب وكالة
رويترز. تركيا والفخاخ السياسية.
عدد القتلى مبالغ به جدا. لتأتي
تصريحات امريكية اخرى عبر منسق
الولايات المتحدة بيع تركيا
مقاتلات اف ستة عشر لتحديث
الاسبانية مع الكيان الاسرائيلي
لتنضم اسكتلندا الى قائمة
مؤيدة لفلسطين في برشلونة
للمطالبة بقطع العلاقات
نتيجة وضعه لحزام الامان وهو في
سيارة حكومية متحركة وسوناك
سيؤدي بالتأكيد الى ركود في
الولايات المتحدة وقد يؤدي الى
التركية سفير السويد لدى انقرة
وابلغته ادانتها للقرار باشد
الامريكية جانت يلين من ان
التخلف عن سداد الديون الامريكية
لفلسطين المحتلة بمن فيهم العرب?
شهدت بطولة كأس امم افريقيا
لحكومة نتنياهو. الاحداث
والتطورات. حذرت وزيرة الخزانة
الامير فيصل بن فرحان على اقامة
دولة فلسطينية قبل التطبيع مع
لتختم الموجة باحتشاد مائتي الف
متظاهر اسرائيلي في تل ابيب رفضا
تركيا باستراتيجية جديدة.
السياسة اولا فلا عدو دائم ولا
الحوار مع الجانب التركي لكن
السويد قد ترتكب خطأ فادحا. حيث
ذكرت تقارير اعلامية غربية ان
الحكومة السويدية وافقت على
اوكرانيا. وقدر مالي الخسائر
البشرية الروسية في اوكرانيا
وتوغل لمسافة سبعة كيلومترات في
عمق الاراضي الخاضعة للسيطرة
الاوكرانية. ليتوعد مؤسسو شركة
فاغنر بارسال عشرين شاحنة محملة
الداعمة للاحتلال الاسرائيلي. في
حين اشترط وزير الخارجية السعودي
للمنتخبات المحلية المقامة حاليا
في الجزائر اجواء رائعة. اذ خطف
الدخول الى الناتو? فماذا انتم
فاعلون يا احفاد عثمان? القدس
في حين وعدت السويد بمد اوكرانيا
بمدافع ارتشر لتتعهد فنلندا
حفيد نيلسون مانديلا الانظار في
حفل افتتاح البطولة بعد تذكيره
زيارتها للسويد قال وزير الدفاع
السويدي انهم يتطلعون لمواصلة
الهولندية اعتزام تزويد كييف
الدفاع الجوي باتريوت. اما
والرد التركي على ذلك الاستفزاز
كان باستدعاء وزارة الخارجية
العبارة لكن هل تستخدم انقرة
استفزازا كهذا لمنع السويد من
الروس انها منظمة اجرامية. مشيرا
الى ان لدى فاغنر حوالي خمسين
فاغنر العسكرية الخاصة
والامريكيون زملاء. مضيفا انه من
الف عنصر في اوكرانيا متوقعا ان
يرتفع ذلك العدد مع مواصلة
بارسال مساعدة عسكرية بقيمة
اربعمائة مليون يورو لاوكرانيا
الصعب جدا في هذا العام دحر
القوات الروسية عسكريا من كامل
اسطولها الحالي وهنا تستمر تركيا
بالسياسة. وبعد ان الغت انقرة
واشنطن حيث قال رئيس هيئة
الاركان الامريكية المشتركة
حاسمة بشأن بيع طائرات اف ستة
عشر الكونجرس بالتخلي عن معارضة
الصفقة لترد الرئاسة الامريكية
انهم يعتقدون انه يجب على
الاخر ان يدخل اولا. قبل ذلك كان
البنتاجون قد اعلن عن مساعدة
صديق دائم. وها هي انقرة تدعو
ادارة الرئيس بايدن الى ان تكون
عسكرية بقيمة مليارين ونصف
المليار دولار وهو ذات المبلغ
الذي اعلنت هولندا انها ستقدمه
لاوكرانيا. كما اعلنت الحكومة
الاحتجاجات حيث اقتحم عدة ناشطين
هناك مصنعا لتطوير الاسلحة
من القرآن الكريم وذلك امام
السفارة التركية في ستوكهولم.
الان فصاعدا يمكن ان تسمى علاقة
فاجنر بواشنطن بتصفية حسابات
لاوكرانيا كما ستوفر الدنمارك
تسعة عشر مدفع قيصر فرنسي الصنع.
قتلى الجيش الاوكراني في مدينة
سوليدر الى ذويهم. ومن كييف الى
ليعلنها بطريرك موسكو الاكبر
كيليل. اي محاولة لتدمير روسيا
الاتصالات الاستراتيجية في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي
تمكن من تدمير خط الدفاع الاول
للجيش الاوكراني في محور زبروجيا
عمليات التجنيد من السجون
الروسية حسب تعبيره. ليأتي الرد
الروسي من مؤسسي فاغنر يفجين
بريجوجن بسخرية قائلا اخيرا شركة
الذي قال ان وزارة الخزانة
الامريكية ستصنف قوات فاجنر
بريطانيا فتعهدت بارسال ستمائة
صاروخ من طراز بريمستون اضافي
باكثر من الف قتيل. اانت متأكد
من هذا العدد يا مارك لترد هنا
الاوكرانية. حيث قالت سلطات
الموالية لموسكو ان الجيش الروسي
ديمتري بيسكوف قائلا ان اسلحة
الناتو لن تحدث تغييرا جذريا في
اعلنت من قبل. وها كانهم امام
كهف الدب الروسي كل منهم يريد من
الخلاف دفع الرئيس الاوكراني
فولوديمرزيليسكي الى القول انه
خمسين دولة في المانيا لدعم كيه.
نعم لقد اجتمعت خمسون دولة في
بعد يا هؤلاء اين ستذهب كل هذه
المبالغ؟ هناك زاد طمع زينيسكي
برلين ان تبدأ واشنطن بتسليم
كييف الدبابات لتفعل هي كذلك كما
وزارة الدفاع الروسية بالنفي
القاطع حول تصريح مارك ميلي وان
اف ستة عشر وصواريخ بعيدة المدى
لبلاده. ليخرج المتحدث الروسي
وفنلندا خلال الاجتماع تسليم
دبابات ليوبرتو الى اوكرانيا شرط
الصمود لتحقيق تقدم ملموس على
الارض. بينما عرضت بولندا
وهي اكبر مساهمة لها حتى الان.
تشمل اسلحة مدفعية وذخيرة. وماذا
في الكرم الغربي. ليطالب من
وزراء دفاع الناتو توفير طائرات
لا بديل عن دبابات حديثة
لاوكرانيا كي تعزز من جيشها على
الحصول على موافقة برلين ليرد
وزير الدفاع الالماني الجديد
والقدس حاضرة في كل مكان لدى
العرب وها هي حاضرة في اوروبا.
وحدها تسليم الدبابات لكييف امر
خاطئ وفق تعبيره. وبذلك تنتظر
الغربي على اوكرانيا بالمليارات.
واشنطن تتملق لتركيا فما الذي
سادة. والحرب تدخل مرحلة حاسمة
واوكرانيا لن نتوقف. ارسلوا لنا
الجنرال مارك ميلي من وجهة نظر
عسكري. ما زلت ارى انه سيكون من
مسار المعارك ستزيد من المشاكل
في اوكرانيا. لنعد الى الحرب
ليو بارد الالمانية. ما تعهدوا
بتقديم مساعدات اضافية. هذا
قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي لويد
اوستن انهم مستمرون في دعم
عامها الثاني حذرت موسكو من نهج
يقود الى كارثة بسبب اجتماع
الخمسين في المانيا قد فشلوا في
الاتفاق على تسليم كييف دبابات
بوريس بيستوريوس ان هناك اختلاف
ولكن القول ان المانيا ترفض
قاعدة الالماني لتدخل الحرب
مرحلة حاسمة في اوكرانيا. حيث
ستعني نهاية العالم. ما هذا الذي
تقوله يا هذا? وللعلم هذا
الروسية الاوكرانية تقترب من
ابتلاع العالم في حرب طاحنة
ستقدم حزمة مساعدات جديدة
لاوكرانيا. لكن حلفاء اوكرانيا
اوكرانيا مهما طال امد الحرب
كانت التكلفة. مضيفا ان واشنطن
محملة بجثث القتلى لكييف خلال
الايام المقبلة. هكذا اعلنتها
اي محاولة للاعتداء علينا ستعني
نهاية العالم وسنرسل عشرين شاحنة
البطريرك لا يتحدث الا بتوجيهات
من وبالتزامن مع دخول الحرب
يجري من تحت الطاولة. بينما
السويد تستفز تركيا والمسلمين.
موسكو تنشر الرعب. هذا العام لن
يكون كالعام الماضي. والحرب
ازمة كبرى. واستراليا توجه طعنة
غدر لفرنسا.
وتل ابيب تطلب النجدة من البابا.
امريكا على حافة كارثة ستدخل في
روسيا وخمسون دولة تجتمع للرد
ليزداد خطر صراع القوى العظمى يا
خارج حدود اوكرانيا. لكن هل تصبح
حربا عالمية برأيكم?
الدبابات فقط فاجنر للامريكان
اهلا بزملائنا لينال الدعم